a été publié aux édition de
l'observatoire c'était en février
dernier vous êtes aussi éditorialiste au
figaro et alors qu'on commence par là
parce que ce matin comme chaque lundi
vous nous régaler de votre chronique
elle est consacrée à boris johnson au
break site qui est imminent on entre
dans la dernière ligne droite
et alors qu'est ce que vous lui mettez à
ce malheureux johnson vous dites il se
rêve en turquie mais en fait il n'est
qu'un chamberlain jean bart là on se
souvient que c'était le premier ministre
qui aux côtés de daladier notamment
avait lâché à hitler les accords de
munich
qu'est ce qui vous a fait ce malheur aux
johnson écoutez le à moi et ne m'a rien
fait mais je pense qu'effectivement il
fait beaucoup de mal aux au royaume uni
et qu'on s'aperçoit de plus en plus que
le break site repose en fait sur une
succession de promesses impossibles et
que ça va coûter très cher au
royaume-uni ça va d'ailleurs coûté cher
à l'europe aussi puisque le le départ du
royaume uni n'est certainement pas une
bonne nouvelle est aujourd'hui
finalement comme toujours le les
populistes explose quand ils sont
confrontés à la réalité donc par les
jeunes seule la réalité le rattrape de
trois manières d'abord l'épidémie
c'est quand même la pire performance et
en termes de morts est en termes de
récession puisqu'elle va atteindre 12%
du du pib' il est rattrapé il avait
beaucoup parier sur donald trump et il
était très fière d'être considérée comme
les mules de donald trump et au royaume
uni évidemment aujourd'hui la fraternité
des hommes de paille paraît plus
compliqué et il a par ailleurs en vrai
problème global donne c'est que sa
politique sur le break site risque de
ranimer les problèmes de frontières en
irlande du nord et que joe biden et est
d'origine irlandaise et la troisième
chose celle breakes site sur lequel il a
fait un espèce de concours de lenteur et
c'est vrai que tout le monde a intérêt à
un accord mais le royaume uni encore
beaucoup plus que l'union européenne
parce que le royaume uni fait 46 % de
ses exportations vers vers l'union donc
si de toute manière ça sera un choc pour
le après le choc de la récession et de
l'épidémie si on veut rajouter un
deuxième choc majeur sur l'économie
britannique
c'est le no deal mais là le cas sera
complètement le l'économie le
développement qui sont déjà bien habillé
je rappelle que depuis 2016 il ya plus
d'investissements au royaume uni c'est
quelque chose que l'état en corse et
laisser les fêtes mais ça va peser à
terme très fortement sur le
développement de de ce pays sur
l'immigration là aussi c'est intéressant
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya plus
d'immigration européenne mais c'est
compensé par de l'immigration asiatique
il ya beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles
on voit que le par exemple fameux le nhs
le service de santé britannique qui
devait massivement être améliorée par le
break site pour l'instant est plutôt
dans un état de très grandes fragile
alors pour pour qualifier la politique
suivie par boris johnson vous avez
utilisé et vous le reprenez à l'instant
ce mot du popu les deux populismes et
alors il ya une définition du populisme
qui ne sera sûrement pas indifférent
alexandre ii vecchio le populisme
écrivez-vous est une maladie
dégénérative de la démocratie contre
laquelle il n'existe pas de vaccin
ben vous voilà habillé pour l'hiver j'ai
un exemple vous qui on le sait bien
avait plutôt une belle idée une haute
idée du populisme non j'essaie de
regarder population le diaboliser je
suis pas un militant
par contre je pense effectivement que le
populisme n'est pas la maladie ses
symptômes de la maladie de l'âme
démocratie parce que la démocratie ça
reste les contre-pouvoirs mais d'abord
et avant tout la souveraineté du peuple
mg on a donc un peuple demos qui a le
sentiment de plus avoir de pouvoir
d'avoir le pouvoir confisqué par les
marchés par les experts par les
technocrates et en cela la réaction des
peuples a été de voter pour le populaire
je disais le peuple demos ou pourra
aussi dire le clown le peuple et n'ose
pas en tant que communauté ethnique mais
en tant que communautés culturelles il
ya aussi le sentiment d'être dépossédés
d'une partie de sa culture d'être en
insécurité culturelle par rapport à une
globalisation économique mais aussi par
une immigration massive et donc là aussi
c'est un mouvement de révolte donc là
donc c'est des symptômes c'est des
symptômes d'une maladie qui vous voyait
avait commencé à mine
les démocraties libérales bien avant les
populismes maintenance sur vos régions
et aussi parce que la démonstration
nicolas baverez ses dires a
effectivement bon et johnson il fait ce
pour quoi il a reçu le mandat du peuple
par une sorte de mouvement populiste et
le résultat c'est une catastrophe parce
que le peuple n'a pas toujours raison
d'abord les résultats catastrophiques du
bric site
j'aimerais bien voir ça on n'y est pas
encore vous êtes le folkeux avant la
crise du coroner virus le taux de
croissance et de chômage du royaume uni
données plutôt envie à la france et même
aujourd'hui c'est indiqué dans sa
chronique il y aurait 6 % de chômeurs au
royaume-uni après qu vide je pense que
les français seraient bien contents
d'avoir des chiffres comme ceux là donc
rien n'est dit je pense qu'ils vont
d'ailleurs parvenir un accord maintenant
si c'est des reproches à faire à bord et
johnson mais c'est pas du tout des de
tenir trop parole et d'être trop pop et
les jeux je crois que il ya eu un
tournant dans le mandat de boris johnson
c'est quand il a eu lui même le co lead
et ça l'a rendu je trouve extrêmement
prudent alors c'est vrai qu'il avait
fait une erreur stratégique au départ
avec l'immunité de groupe mais on sont
de plus en plus une reprise en main de
ce qu'on pourra appeler l'état profond
britannique le parti conservateur
traditionnel boris johnson a à limoger
dominique henning qui était son
conseiller qui avait inspiré sa
stratégie justement de de s'adresser à
la classe ouvrière industrielle
britannique dont il ya un changement de
pied qui est aussi lié au fait que
effectivement donald trump a perdu et
j'ai peur que boris johnson deviennent
finalement assez conformiste
il faut pas qu'il faut qu'ils se
souviennent par qui il a été parqué là
été élu parce que si il nous fait du
but tony blair et bien il sera battu et
subira le même sort que ses
prédécesseurs
une réaction d'un internaute celle de
christophe 78 ce qui nous dit depuis le
temps qu'ils nous disent
alors c'est peut-être les gens qui qui
qui font la même analyse que vous
nicolas baverez depuis le temps qu'ils
nous disent que la grande bretagne va
s'enfoncer dans l'eau elle est toujours
bien vivante
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu un peu
sombre et pour l'avenir du royaume uni
parce qu'après tout il va retrouver de
la liberté par rapport à l'europe il
sera débarrassé de des normes tout ce
qui nous gêne regardez sur l'histoire
des vaccins ils vont pouvoir vacciner
avant nous parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
contraintes c'était une bonne chose
d'abord moi je ne souhaite qu'une chose
comme je vous le disais je pense que
pour l'europe en général le fait d'avoir
le royaume uni à bord et un royaume uni
qui se porte bien c'est évidemment un
avantage on a quand même des nations
aujourd'hui l'europe est quand même dans
une situation très très difficile et le
fait par exemple en matière de défense
voir le royaume uni qui représentait le
tiers du potentiel militaire qui se
retrouvent en dehors c'est sûrement pas
une bonne nouvelle
reprenons l'histoire des vaccins très
franchement moi je suis pour qu'on
puisse le plus vite possible vacciner la
population annoncé qu on commence une
campagne de vaccins 23 jours après l
annonce par le laboratoire alors même
que les données n'ont pas été publiées
sur le résultat du stade de duty dernier
stade des essais cliniques
très franchement je pense que c'est
quand même singulièrement risqués et par
ailleurs pour l'instant toute façon il y
en a très peu qui sont disponibles mais
si on en revient à la vraie
interrogation pourquoi est ce que c'est
un contresens historique parce qu'à
partir de l'union européenne oui parce
que la mondialisation ne disparaît pas
elle est en train de changer
profondément donc le moment de la
mondialisation libérale il est terminé
en revanche on voit que le système
mondial se structure autour de deux
grands blocs
ce qui vaut cher aujourd'hui ce qui
permet aux européens de tenir
c'est ce grand marché qui pour le coup
compte vis-à-vis des etats-unis de la
chine est grand et des grands émergents
ce qui peut nous permettre de résister à
la chine qui est en train d'essayer
d'acheter nos actifs à bas prix à la
russie qui avec son arsenal fait quand
même peser une menace de la baltique à
la méditerranée en passant par l'ukraine
à la turquie qui multiplie les fronts si
vous voulez ça n'est pas pays par pays
qu'on peut résister gilles c'est pour ça
que la stratégie de l'union européenne
et est valide et surtout si on se met à
la place des britanniques
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que ils
ont gâché la plus belle position
il avait quand même une position où
c'étaient eux qui intellectuellement
avait pris le pouvoir à bruxelles
il avait inspiré le grand marché il
avait la première place financière du
continent tout en étant ni membre de
schengen donc en fait ils maîtrisaient
parfaitement l'immigration s'il en avait
eu envie et il n'était pas dans l'euro
est pour prix de tout ça ils paient la
moitié de la cotisation au club
bah oui c'est encore trop voilà
apparemment si on en croit les électeurs
mais soyons soyons clairs le lecteur
britannique avait parfaitement le droit
de choisir et d'ailleurs on a bien vu
contre contrairement à tous les gens qui
disaient l'europe empêche les gens de
voter les gens pêche que l'europe
empêche les gens banon les britanniques
ont voté ça va rentrer en application
peut il n'empêche que c'est une cata
mais c'est un argument d'autorité enfin
on entend quand même depuis le vote a eu
lieu maintenant 2015 depuis cinq ans
quand même on attend la catastrophe
depuis cinq ans elle n'est toujours pas
arrivé je crois que tout n'est pas non
plus économique
je crois que les a prévenu les
britanniques que sa lettre soit disant
une catastrophe économique j'y crois pas
du tout mais ils ont préféré la liberté
au tout économique je crois et ensuite
ce que vous dites sur l'europe est vrai
sur le plan théorique
effectivement on pourrait penser qu'à
plusieurs on est plus fort et que face
aux empires on pourrait créer une sorte
de vampire européens sauf que c'est un
empire nous et que ce n'est pas vrai
kessé d'un empire qui nous défend ce
serait bien effectivement que on est un
marché qu'ils soient défendus orge
observe que face à la chine
les européens ont été les ravines
la crèche de la mondialisation heureuse
observe que face à la turquie
heureusement que la france donne un peu
de la voix
ça suffit pas hélas non on voit bien que
le fait de se mettre d'accord à 27 ça ne
permet pas d'avoir une politique commune
cohérente est forte donc moi je crois
totalement l'inversé de vous je crois
qu'avec des états-nations fort qu'ils se
mettraient d'accord
finalement on poserait plus qu'avec ce
grand machin où on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord à 25 vert à 0 c'est que
les états-nations fort ne sont pas
incompatibles avec l'union européenne
farid et les formes de coopération
robert où on a forcément celle ci mais
on se donne rendez vous dans quelques
mois pour voir si la catastrophe
annoncée est effectivement intervenus je
termine par quelques commentaires
d'internautes qui partage plutôt
l'euroscepticisme d'alexandre chris
kraus nous dit on nous avait promis la
prospérité et pas de chômage
en parlant de l'europe ait pu nicole 06
aussi honnêtement de toutes les
promesses de l'union il n'y en a pas
beaucoup qui ont été tenus et jean paul
2 2x qui ajoute l'europe marque serait
beaucoup mieux si les états unis
n'utilisent et par le royaume uni pour
nous savonner la planche
revenons en france si vous le voulez
bien pour parler quelques minutes des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu samedi
dernier manifestations de protestation
contre la loi sur la sécurité globale
protestations qui se sont une fois de
plus accompagné d' images violentes de
magasins et de vitrines brisées de
voitures incendiées de forces de l'ordre
blessés soixante sept au total
à tel point que certains se posent la
question est ce qu'on peut encore
organiser des manifestations sachant que
à chaque fois ou presque
il y à des blacks blocs et des éléments
violents à chaque fois ou presque et ce
presque n'avait pas échappé à marine le
pen elle était hier soir sur lci écouter
ont déjà ça fait cinq ans que ça dure ça
fait cinq ans que chaque manifestation
enfin pas chaque d'ailleurs que les
manifestations de sans papiers a pas de
black blocks
bon moi j'en suis pas très étonné de la
même manière les manifestations
d'extrême gauche contre l'islamophobie
etc il n'y a pas de dégâts nicolas
baverez
effectivement si on met de côté ces
manifestations où il n'y a pas de dérive
elles sont presque devenus la norme est
ce que du coup sachant que les forces de
l'ordre ne veulent pas arrêter les black
blocks par peur devait d'avoir des
blessés ou même des mots est ce qu'il
faut pas se dire bon à la manifestation
à l'ancienne c'est un truc terminée il
faut inventer inventer des nouveaux
modes de protestation
évidemment évidemment non parce que le
droit de manifester
c'est un droit fondamental dans une
démocratie le problème de la france
aujourd'hui c'est que le gouvernement a
complètement perdu le contrôle de
l'ordre public donc on a aujourd'hui on
est en crise sur les deux bouts de la
chaîne c'est à dire premièrement on a
une violence qui explose donc les
problèmes de manifestations on l'a vu
avec les gilet jaune là
les protestations contre les retraites
maintenant effectivement contre la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale
on a une également une montée de la
délinquance et surtout on a en plus sans
problème de terrorisme dont on a vu
récemment à quel point ils restaient
importants et avec des deux nouveaux de
nouvelles tragédies
de l'autre côté on est en train
d'accumuler des textes lois ou
proposition loi après proposition de loi
alors même qu'on n'est pas capable
d'appliquer ce qui existe et on est en
train de prendre de vrais risques sur
les libertés publiques dans notre pays
avec ce que dit emmanuel macron et qui
me paraît très contestable tant que je
suis là il n'y a pas de problème mais le
problème d'un état de droit c'est que
justement il n'est pas fait dans une
démocratie pourquoi est ce qu'on a à
droit c'est que il est parfaitement
normal qu'on change de dirigeants
régulièrement c'est le vote populaire et
en même temps il ya des principes qui
est des principes juridiques qui font
que les libertés sont garantis quel que
soit celui qui fait il dirige est donc
aujourd'hui parce que de fait il ya eu
un très grand manque pendant la première
partie de ce quinquennat surtout le
régalien et qu'en matière de justice et
de police notamment ça a été plus qu'un
dirigeant
on est en train d'essayer de faire un
espèce donc d'un côté on a perdu le
contrôle de l'ordre public et de l'autre
côté on fait un effet de rattrapage avec
la multiplication de deux textes qui
sont en partie inutiles et en partie
liberticide
donc voilà le voilà la situation absurde
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait en sortir
il faut re sortait toujours de la même
manière c'est à dire d'abord en essayant
d'appliquer les lois qui existent
ensuite en investissant dans l'état
régalien en améliorant la formation des
policiers en améliorant leur équipement
en améliorant leur éthique sans doute en
réformant l'igpn est
et on faisant en sorte que le en matière
de cons est une autorité indépendante
pour regarder les incidents qui se
déroule dans les manifestations pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir confiance
dans ce système donc c'est comme ça
qu'on pourrait faire avancer les choses
beaucoup plus que avec cette espèce de
spirale un bon on avait une vraie
dynamique aujourd'hui de la violence qui
est en train d'apporter notre société et
qui abîme beaucoup notre démocratie
les internautes
du figaro sont très sévères sur l'action
du gouvernement c'est pas forcément une
surprise quand on voit les images
quant au temps qu'ils ont encore été
diffusée ce week-end à la question le
gouvernement en fait ils suffisamment
contre les casseurs
vous êtes une immense majorité à
répondre non quatre vingts plus de 90%
alexandre vécu honnêtement quand les
policiers disent on pourrait charger les
arrêter mais il risquerait d'y avoir des
blessés et des morts et la société
française n'est pas prête à accepter ça
ce que vous admettez ce cet argument ou
est ce que vous pensez comme certains en
particulier à l'extrême gauche que
peut-être que ça arrange le gouvernement
de discréditer ce genre de mouvement en
laissant faire les black blocks je pense
que les policiers moi j'ai pas entendu
les policiers de dire ça risque de faire
des morts ils disent les autorités nous
empêche de le faire nous on aimerait
bien le faire on est extrêmement frustré
mais les autorités
nous nous empêche pourquoi on ne sait
pas de deux images qui est fait
il ya effectivement le mal est poussé
kenneth starr mais c'est vrai que
j'observe le syndrome pop up ou et
manifestations les années j'observe que
pendant les gilet jaune n'y a pas eu de
problème pour tirer au flashball pour
éborgné des gens de manière souvent
d'ailleurs excessive
donc il ya une forme de complaisance
vis-à-vis des balades bloc est
d'ailleurs assez vrac on peut se dire
que pendant les manifs de gilet jaune on
peut se dire que les black blocks ont
quand même terni l'image du mouvement et
que bizarrement on a chargé
enfin on a été au contact avec les
gilles et je ne mets pas avec les black
blocks donc est ce qu'il ya une
stratégie je crois que si c'est une
stratégie elle est tout de même mauvaise
parce que ça donne en ça donne l'image
d'un gouvernement qu'il s installer le
désordre et ça donne l'image aussi d'un
très grand deux poids deux mesures
puisque d'un côté on a les yeux
réglementation tous azimuts les amendes
pour ceux qui auraient le masque de dhr
à travers etc et de l'autre côté
effectivement tous les samedis
on détruit tout à paris donc donc voilà
il ya un problème d'autorité de l'état
à mon avis il est possible effectivement
de 10 palier en ayant du courage puisque
les policiers disent que c'est
impossible d'intervenir on peut aussi
intervenir en amont alors là il ya
d'autres problèmes qui a été celui du
conseil constitutionnel qui avait
censuré une loi qui permettait
effectivement de d'intervenir en amont
il ya ce problème de l'état de droit
mais je pense qu'avec du courage on
arrive à résoudre à résoudre ce problème
les internautes s'en sortent assez
d'accord avec vous en tout cas ce qui ce
se qui s'exprime
il y avait cette loi anti casseurs qui
avaient pour but d'encadrer les
manifestations rappelle babineau mais
qui a été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel a tandis qu archos 10
affirment que le droit de manifester dès
pas d'autorisation de tout casser de
tout brûler pour répondre à votre
question moi je suis radicalement en
revanche contre le fait d'interdire les
manifestations peut-être dans cette
période puisque tout est interdit donc
ma pas les manifestations mais enfin ce
serait un recul de l'autorité de l'état
serait une manière de casser le
thermomètre celle que la barre et on
vous a souvent entendu ici défendre les
libertés publiques l'état de droit
bah oui mais résultat c'est qu'avec ces
grands principes on ne peut pas arrêtées
préventivement des gens dont on se doute
bien qu'ils vont [ __ ] le bazar et tout
casser dans les manifestations mais le
problème des arrestations préventives
évidemment c'est un énorme problème de
liberté mais ce que rappelait être juste
titre alexandre de big youth et que le
ce que disent les policiers c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
là encore l'arsenal il existe qui est
vrai c'est que aujourd'hui les policiers
interviennent très peu contre des gens
qui sont en train de commettre des
saccages organisé mais évidemment il ya
dans notre droit tout ce qu'il faut pour
sanctionner les gens qui commettent ces
actes
il se trouve simplement comme on l'a dit
que pour l'instant ils ont une forme de
ils ont une forme d'impunité et c'est
vrai que c'est insupportable quand on
voit aujourd'hui l'état de l'économie de
ce pays que précisément parmi les
secteurs sinistrés il ya le commerce et
qu'on rajoute à la fois la dévastation
d'un certain nombre de commerces
le fait que des quartiers entiers sont
saccagés pour un pays qui est maintenant
un pays très appauvrie enfin c'est
absolument incroyable qu'on laisse faire
ça et il est vrai que les policiers sont
une fois de plus comme les enseignants
comme beaucoup de com les pompiers comme
beaucoup de jeux d'acteurs publics comme
les soignants ils sont lâchés en rase
campagne c'est-à-dire qu'on leur demande
on leur dit d'un côté vous n'avez pas le
droit d'intervenir ou vous devez et de
l'autre côté c'est à vous de faire face
à la violence dans la société est
évidemment de toute manière ça n'est pas
possible de le faire uniquement avec
deux avec de la répression
et il ya une faillite de l'état en
matière d'ordre public comme il ya une
faillite de l'état en matière
d'éducation et comme on l'a vu il ya un
système de santé qui a été complètement
complètement milliers mis à l'abandon et
ceci alors que avant même le coc vide
cet état absorbe quand même 57% du pipe
de la nation donc c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui ne
ne ne va vraiment plus comment est-ce
qu'on peut arriver un désastre inde et à
corbeil alors peut-être y at-il des
économies à faire dans le système de
santé avec ce que l'on appelle la m e
l'aide médicale d'état vous savez c'est
ce procédé je ne sais pas comment dire
ça ce système qui permet aux immigrés en
situation irrégulière de pouvoir être
soigné en france le nombre de
bénéficiaires est de plus en plus
importants regardez ce graphique
il était dans le figaro de ce matin ça
augmente encore plus vite que la dette
de l'état à ses dires le entre 2003 et
2010 neuf le nombre de locataires de la
m e est passé de 180 milles à plus de
330 milles résultat un budget de plus
d'un milliard d'euros devra être
consacré à cette aide qui fait l'objet
de nombreuses dérives un toujours dans
notre dossier du figaro il y a ce
témoignage du didier leschi qui est un
très grand spécialiste de ce sujet et
qui dit vous savez bien sûr il ya des
malades qui viennent du maghreb de
l'afrique et qui utilise la m mais il ya
aussi des américains ou des suisses qui
viennent se faire soigner en france en
profitant entre guillemets de ce système
avec une sorte de tourisme médical
alexandre avec eux quand on lit ce genre
de témoignages on se dit qu évidemment
on peut améliorer le système mais là je
pense comme vous seraient d'accord là
dessus c'est pas forcément la peine dans
des maps mais sur le principe est ce que
pour vous c'est
c'est l'honneur de la france c'est ce
qu'on appelait ya très longtemps son
devoir d'état que d'aider tous les gens
qui sont encore des problèmes de santé y
compris des immigrés clandestins nous
très clairement non je suis favorable à
ce que dans les situations d'urgence on
puisse accueillir les gens même des
clandestins ça j'y suis favorable et
c'est ce qui se pratique d'ailleurs dans
les autres pays européens mais là il
s'agit pas de ça il s'agit d'un panier
santé qui est le même que pour un
citoyen français qui cotisent ils ont le
droit à tout sauf à la paix m
donc et en plus ça encourage un certain
nombre de trafics de fraude sur laquelle
on pourra revenir tout à l'heure donc on
voit bien que ce principe de
l'universalité poussé à l'extrême où il
faudrait accueillir toutes là toute la
misère du monde
nenê n'est pas tenable tout simplement
si on veut conserver un modèle social
aux français auxquels on tient si on
veut permettre aux gens qui ont cotisé
toute leur vie d'en bénéficier
il va falloir que cette universalité
cesse sinon ce système va imploser
nicolas pas vrai quelle est votre
opinion certains disent qu'il faudrait
établir par exemple des formes de deux
dispensaires on pourrait être soigné ces
gens sans qu'ils bénéficient de
l'ensemble du système de santé français
d'abord c'est pas une question d'honneur
c'est une question d'intérêt et de santé
publique
autrement dit dans les sociétés
développées il ya toujours des
clandestins ces clandestins ils peuvent
être les vecteurs d'un certain nombre de
maladies
il voit avec évidence en ce moment
puisqu'on à une pandémie et il est clair
qu'on n'a aucun intérêt par exemple à
avoir des clandestins qui se balade avec
le coït partout dans la société donc il
ya un intérêt de santé publique à ce que
les gens ce qu'ils sont sur notre
territoire soit soigné pour des
pathologies qui peuvent mettre en danger
le reste de la population contagieuse
exactement
et donc ce que font toutes les autres
démocraties c'est que il ya des formes
de qui correspondent à peu près à cette
aide médicale d'état mais qui sont
concentrés sur un panier de soins de
base et qui sont encadrés et le paradoxe
est effectivement là où système français
à complètement dérivés c'est que même la
dépense par personne dans ce régime qui
n'en est pas en est supérieure à la
dépense par personne dans le régime
général et
et c'est lille sasol ses 1600 et 1700 à
1800 euros par tête et ça c'est
évidemment complètement anormal donc on
a un effet d'appel
et c'est vrai que ball ensuite donc pour
lime ce qu'il faudrait faire est assez
évident c'est que là aussi il faut
regarder ce que font les étrangers c'est
à dire que on n'a aucun intérêt à
laisser des gens gravement malade
circuler sur le territoire français mais
il va de soi que ça doit être un panier
de base qui est extrêmement précis
restreint évidemment il n'est pas
question d'accueillir gratuitement et de
manière illimitée des gens qui font du
tourisme médical pour venir se faire
soigner en france
le problème qui se trouve derrière par
ailleurs que vous avez rappelé et que le
nombre de bénéficiaires a donc doublé en
15 ans et donc derrière ça pose la
question de l'absence de régulation de
l'immigration et de la constitution
d'une immigration clandestine dont il ya
trois cent mille bénéficiaires de l'aeeh
meuse si on pense avec patrick stefanini
ou à certains n'ont d'autre que rapport
est de 1 3 ça voudrait dire qu'il ya 900
mille clandestins en france
c'est sûrement déjà beaucoup en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
beaucoup et que c' est absolument
impensable que ça continue à augmenter
dans les mêmes proportions
donc c'est le problème qui a derrière
l'allemagne le problème de lyme est
assez clair et je pense que la solution
raisonnable est celle qui est en vigueur
dans les autres démocraties la question
évidemment de l'immigration clandestine
est une bonne amie une question
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué
effectivement pour vous dire le point de
vue de nos lecteurs qui sont favorables
nos internautes pendant qu'ils sont
favorables majoritairement à la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'état
mais c'est pas écrasant non plus puisque
c'est 58 % favorables à sa suppression
contre 42% et je vous reparle oui mais
encore une fois je pense que si on
précisait qu on disait on soigne ceux
qui sont vraiment voilà dans des
situations d'urgence tous
tout le monde serait d'accord pour dire
que là il ya une dérive ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement la
hem révèle un nombre important de
clandestins en france près d'un million
donc mais en plus on peut se dire que ce
système est aussi une forme d'appel
d'air effectivement si on est un pays
qui soigne tout le monde qui offre un
certain nombre de prestations à tout le
monde ça encourage malgré tout à venir
et ça pose de manière plus large la
question des dépenses sociales à l'heure
où on n'a pas assez de l'ue d'hôpitaux
pour soigner tout le monde où je
rappelle qu'on n'a pas eu assez de
respirateurs etc etc
je crois que le problème de la dépense
sociale est un des problèmes
fondamentaux en france dans le livre de
charles prat qui parle de la fraude
sociale la dépense sociale de manière
plus large on voit que 50 % des
bénéficiaires de la caf sont nés à
l'étranger la cafsa comprend les
allocations familiales mais aussi toutes
sortes d'allocations allocations
logement rsa etc
je pense que c'est un système trop
généreux et que le courage politique
mais pas n'était pas de faire la rgpp
comme l'ont fait françois fillon et
nicolas sarkozy ras des politiques
publiques pour faire des économies mais
c'était supprimer de manière notre
philippe séguin disait que c'était la
politique du rabot c'était supprimer un
fonctionnaire sur deux qu'on a par
ailleurs remis dans les collectivités
telus et territoriales mais c'est pas
grave et on a ainsi démanteler un
système de service public qui était
plutôt efficace on en paie aujourd'hui
les conséquences on voit tous les jours
dans la police mais aussi à l'hôpital il
aura été plus courageux de s'attaquer au
système social
et là encore on s'attaque aux retraites
on peut on peut en discuter
effectivement on vit plus longtemps
peut-être travailler plus longtemps mais
on comprend que les français renac à ce
type de réforme
quand on voit qui aurait 50 milliards
de fraude sociale encore une fois je
crois que les français sont attachés au
modèle social qui est né de la
résistance mais celui ci ne peut pas
être ouvert au monde entier sinon de
toute manière il implosera kriss kross
réagi sur internet il nous dit que la
droite la droite sous chirac n'a rien
fait probablement sous sarkozy non plus
d'ailleurs si c'est votre ce que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant chris core
c'est à dire le fait que ni la droite ni
la gauche n'ont de son revenu sur l'aide
médicale d'état les politiques n'ont
aucun courage dans ce pays a ajouté vous
archos guy qui nous dit que la mg n'est
que la partie visible de l'iceberg de ce
que coûte l'immigration et maric est
très critique aussi les gouvernements se
succèdent et ruinent peu à peu le
système social acquis par nos parents
nicolas baverez est ce que vous seriez
choqué s'il existait en matière de santé
une forme de préférence nationale celle
d'actions ne traitait pas de la même
façon les immigrés mais cette fois en
situation légale et les français oui ça
me choquerait que un immigré en
situation légale quelqu'un qui travaille
qui cotisent et je vois pas du tout
pourquoi il serait traité d'une autre
manière que quand français et qui soit
le
le problème qu'on a là c'est un problème
qui est extrêmement différents c'est à
dire le problème d'un dispositif ouverts
à des clandestins de manière gratuite
illimitée et avec des gens qui finissent
par avoir un système plus favorables que
ceux qui cotisent
mais très franchement il va de soi que
un émigré qui est en situation régulière
et qui travaille il doit être traité
absolument commun national donc la
différence allait oui elle est sur le
fait qu' effectivement il travaille le
problème je je parlais d'un appel d'air
et d'un système social trop généreux
l'immigration qui travaille et c'est qui
est intégré aucun social a aucun
problème pour qu elles bénéficier du
système social
or on sait qu'il ya également beaucoup
de chômeurs dans l'émigration et que et
que ce système social n'a ainsi pas
forcément les gens qui arrivent à
travailler
donc c'est un problème façon clair il ya
un problème majeur de travail en france
mais le problème du travail en france
c'est pas le problème seulement des
limites non mais je vois là il faut être
clair on a mis en place un système qui
est extrêmement dissuasif sur le travail
d'auteur donc on a une toute petite
partie de gens qui travaillent
énormément et on a une masse de gens qui
ne travaillent pas et qui ont courbé par
cet énorme système social qui fait
qu'apple avait paru injuste acheter et
comme il faut être clair je j'ajoute que
ma langue a fourché parce que je vous ai
posé l'action sur le système de santé je
voulais vous poser la question sur le
système social et pas spécifiquement sur
le fait évidemment de soigner les gens
on sera tous d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut les soigner de la même façon
surtout quand ils sont là ce sera le
mojo du lion avec sans être précis jeu
des fonds le système le modèle social le
système de retraite le système de
sécurité sociale etc
mais quand je parle je sais ce qu'est ce
qui me pose problème c'est un système
social qui c'est qui a dérivé avec tout
un tas d'allocations qui effectivement
décourage le travail et des immigrés
mais aussi des français
merci beaucoup merci à si vous voulez 2
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous demain pour un nouveau
numéro de point de vue bonne soirée
[Musique]